[Music]
we must
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you thank you this piece is in
three movements
we're only showing two tonight because
it's not finished
and it is emerging judith is emerging
what we're trying to do is listen to the
peace that
wants to be made and wants to be born
this
anglo-saxon epic uh in modern english
and anglo-saxon so let's see what we
think about that
let's all do it
so have a non will become heathen right
in modern english yeah
and that that a e ligature
is called an ash and it's a really
strong sound
so yeah my my professor chick chickering
and
always used to say like quack quack
quack stay with stay with me in duck
land people
so like if you see if you have any
quacks
um quack will become what
will become where in modern english
it sounds sort of like what is emerged
having done so much shakespeare
and realizing that when the characters
in shakespeare speak their hearts their
minds their
their guts they are on the ground of the
english language they speak
monosyllabically
and so you know sort of always i've
walked with karen for a couple of
shakespeare productions
and she loved that's an anglo-saxon word
and it means a lot to her to point that
out
when when shakespeare uses that right
yeah we were talking with the students
last friday about from macbeth the
famous line
the multitudinous sees incarnating both
latinate
complex words and then making the green
one red
and how he puts them right next to each
other sort of to bang it to you
that he's bringing those together it's
oftentimes an anglo-saxon word that is
the
yeah he was not dead yet and make that
funny because it is funny
like the it's the monty python
that's great because the bard is going
to have this sense of
he's the interlocutor for the audience
so there's that sense of being
funny and knowing a lot and playing with
the modern and the ancient
you're almost un taking away the layers
of what becomes the subsequent power
structure right the norman conquest and
that latinate
um dominance over the english accent
which fits with the judah's story right
of being the heroine
from the hebrew people against dominant
[Music]
assyrians
[Music]
yes
and the hardest part is letting the
natural rhythm of the text
sing like there are ways in which it has
a function you know it has a metric
quality to it if you wanted to like
splice lines and do the motherboard
yeah then your rhythms
oh
there are no living anglo-saxons who are
gonna like
[Applause]
[Music]
and loving it and loving judah's prayer
the sound
if you can give us that double d in bid
sure that would be great
we have many good models we have amazing
models of opera
and of creative work and so the question
that i
i'm asking and that we're asking is what
can we make that
is uniquely ours and uniquely the vision
that we have and the sounds that we have
and
um i think the biggest hurdle to get
over at least for me and writing the
music is
we have benjamin britton we have igor
stravinsky we've got status we've got
all these wonderful people who've
written a great
great work and what i mean i'm going to
write
an opera i think that for me was the
biggest hurdle was just actually
believing that i could
make something that could be that long
you know
you can write a choral piece you can
write a piano piece but to write a long
extended work takes
it actually takes an incredible amount
of discipline in my experience
and also willingness to say no that
wasn't great
try again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah just yesterday we're changing a
line because the characters
needs to speak differently and that's
been the fun thing for me is is noticing
that these characters are coming alive
in our presence
and in our conversation and then in the
people who are actually fleshing them
and they're talking they're talking to
us
and we're learning about them and we're
learning what they might say or
actually what they might not say uh and
that's powerful
this this is a powerful time for
discovery does it solve for condo or
is there gonna be any downbeat i mean i
feel like i feel like honestly i'm ready
to hand it over
to you at this moment because there's no
reason we're always told that artists
have a lot of ego but honestly you have
to
kill your darlings over and over and
over again when you create a piece
because you know i come to them so this
really doesn't make sense to me or this
doesn't work
like you know that is really awkwardly
written for my voice
can we you know adjust can we flush it
out judith wouldn't say this here you
know and they
have been so amenable and open and
collaborative and as an artist that's so
nice oftentimes singers are on the
bottom of the totem pole
in in the opera world especially but we
are artists too and have just as many
thoughts and we're just not
always allowed to speak them aloud so
this has been a treat for me
to get to be part of the creation of
judith
[Music]
but it's almost like akin to
cantillation or cantering or it has a
kind of
mysterious quality like that where it's
summoning feels like it's summoning
forth something
yeah and he's also kind of a fun playful
body character too with noticing other
things that character
right is totally made up but it's sort
of teresia's
sort of punk uh ariel
[Music]
that character who can go into the
future into the past
and have humor you know to connect to
to twist to spin but in a way that's
implicating an audience
of the woman i did not want to go on
into the seductive judith it didn't
interest me we've seen that so many
times
rather than more the truth to power
something can be done
[Music]
with paul and carr and i'm i'm very
opinionated person and they
are very patient with me
[Music]
in sleep you are a king
[Music]
she has blood in her hands even though
that was
the thing that she had
[Music]
there's a rabbinical commentary that
talks about when the israelites crossed
the red sea
god permitted the israelites to rejoice
in the
killing of the egyptians but god forbade
the angels
to rejoice and it's that kind of living
with that interesting
weird tension that the sacredness of
life
and yet also justice
or the need for something that feels
like it it honors this
the ache of the human soul of the
oppressed soul
[Music]
you're finding the tone of
humor and the passing of the light
sacred
and the responsibility trying to really
find
what that is i mean yeah it's still
percolating and fighting and there's
this sort of tight ready to walk
[Music]
it goes one direction and pulls back
sometimes between the modern and the
archaic
and that's been very fluid in the
various scenes
it's to find the tone of that
question and also the humor
so i don't know
[Music]
[Music]
you